le Parti libéral du Québec prévoit des
dépenses budgétaires et fiscales de près
de 41 milliards de dollars sur cinq ans
si les portait au pouvoir le PLK a
présenté son cadre financier hier matin
le parti qui prévoit 12 milliards sur
cinq ans en baisse d'impôts 10 milliards
pour une allocation aux années et 2
milliards et demi pour bonifier la
déduction pour les travailleurs
expérimentés le cadre prévoit aussi des
revenus fiscaux de près de 10 milliards
de dollars 3 milliards 400 millions dans
les paradis fiscaux 2 milliards dans la
lutte contre le travail au noir près de
2 milliards également venant d'une taxe
supplémentaire sur les institutions
financières le Parti libéral qui prévoit
un retour à l'équilibre budgétaire dans
7 ans avec nous ce soir Frédéric
Beauchemin candidat pour le Parti
libéral dans Marguerite Bauges bourgeois
bonsoir Monsieur Beauchemin merci de
votre patience à notre table vous avez
été directeur général les chefs des
marchés des capitaux à la banque
scotienne n'est-ce pas pourquoi vous
lancez en politique
l'objectif principal pour moi d'être en
politique c'est de pouvoir être capable
de redonner à la société le véhicule
politique pour moi je trouve c'est le
véhicule le plus
significatif pour justement contribuer
positivement à la société et là la
proposition que vous faites c'est des
dépenses fiscales budgétaires de 41
milliards de dollars pas de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire des déficits
structurels en fait au cours des
prochaines années pourquoi ce plan il
faut comprendre que premièrement de
façon relative il est difficile
représentent un peu moins de 1% du PIB
donc sur un échelle des cinq prochaines
années le traciot dette équité va
diminuer continuer à diminuer
actuellement on est à 38% d'être net sur
le PIB on prévoit qu'on va être aux
alentours de 33% dans 5 ans donc la
dette baisse par rapport à l'école à
l'économie et qui lui ont toutes nos
dépenses même si on fait des déficites
exactement on est loin de l'époque de
Monsieur l'etao par exemple de monsieur
quateux qui voulait atteindre
l'équilibre budgétaire et qu'il
atteignait c'est pas la même situation
fiscale dans lequel le Québec se trouve
actuellement à l'époque initiale du
mandat que vous parlez il y avait
effectivement un ratio de dette qui
était de loin beaucoup plus
problématique les agences de crédit nous
en parler donc c'est important de serrer
la ceinture à cette époque-là on n'est
pas dans le même contexte cependant
aujourd'hui on est fait face à une crise
d'inflation on va faire face
éventuellement probablement une crise de
récession donc prévoyez une récession
ben nous dans nos cartons on croit qu'il
y a des probabilités sont au-dessus de
50% donc on voit ça comme étant une
forte mobilité on se doit donc d'agir
maintenant pour aider les Québécois et
les québécoisses aujourd'hui à faire
face à ce qui s'en vient mais pourquoi
maintenant agir avec une baisse d'impôts
avec une baisse de TVQ en amputant les
moyens de l'État avant même que
l'économie soit en récession ça va
adoucir le choc l'objectif étant de
faire en sorte que ça soit le plus petit
atterrissage possible donc l'objectif
étant de faire en sorte que les
Québécois et les Québécoises puissent
subir de moindre le choc de cette
récession l'équilibre budgétaire c'est
dans 7 ans dites-vous mais dans le
programme on le voit pas même qu'on se
rend jusqu'à 6,7 milliards de dollars de
déficit à l'année 5 il va se passer
entre la maison et l'année 7 tout d'un
coup pour revenir à l'équilibre mais il
faut comprendre que les revenus de
l'État la croissance des états devrait
donc être au rendez-vous tranquillement
pas vite dans les années qui vont suivre
alors si on croit que nous nous estimés
en termes de revenus
nos revenus autonomes sont probablement
très conservateurs on s'attend à ce que
les chiffres soient plus favorables ok
donc c'est pas dans le cas de financier
votre projection de croissance de
revenus n'apparaît pas dans le cadre
conservateur dans nos chiffres on
industrie d'un cadre financier on reste
conservateur en utilisant ces
chiffres-là on s'attend à ce que notre
assiette PIB se maintiennent ou
descendre jusqu'à 33%. pourquoi baisse
quand je vous dis par exemple qu'on
entend des gens dire baisser les impôts
surtout de 12 milliards c'est amputé
l'état amputé les revenus de l'État pour
investir en santé investir en éducation
dans la lutte contre les changements
climatiques pourquoi pas simplement une
aide ponctuelle contre l'inflation de
façon structurante les Québécois aiment
probablement mieux avoir
l'assurance que des années qui vont
suivre leur source de revenus ou
inconstantes de faire un chèque cette
année peut-être pas l'année prochaine
peut-être l'année suivante il y a pas
vraiment moyen de bien planifier ces
finances personnelles donc pour être
plus apte à mieux planifier leur avenir
le Parti libéral du Québec considère que
la baisse d'impôt et la chose à faire
mais si il est difficile sont grands
est-ce qu'on remonte les impôts dans
quelques années c'est pas du tout comme
vous pouvez voir dans notre programme
c'est pas du tout un cadre financier de
restriction budgétaire au contraire on
investit dans la population on aide les
écoles on aide des jeunes on garde notre
contribution au fond des générations on
n'est pas en train d'hypothéquer
l'avenir de nos enfants au contraire ce
qu'on veut faire c'est aider le Québec
dans son ensemble à faire face à la
récession puis en situation de crise en
situation de crise inflation si le rôle
de l'État est de justement prendre ça
sur ses épaules et encaisser des
déficits qui sont minimes relativement
parlant on se doit de le faire c'est le
rôle de l'État le taux d'imposition des
300000 et plus vous parlez d'un nouveau
taux qui serait de combien augmenter de
2% à 27.5 %, 27 et 40% si je peux
d'accord donc deux points de pourcentage
de plus pour une nouvelle un nouveau
taux d'imposition exactement et plus
d'argent dans les paradis fiscaux moi
j'ai dû ça souvent dans les cartes
financiers oui je vous comprends tout le
monde a mentionné cette histoire là mais
c'est exactement le rapport du shérif du
vérificateur général c'est exactement
les chiffres qui sont mentionnés par les
ministères
des Finances donc c'est des chiffres qui
sont atteignables c'est pas une question
si c'est possible ou pas c'est une
question de volonté nous on avait mis en
place le Parti libéral avait mis en
place à l'époque des initiatives pour y
aller de l'avant dès que la carte est
rentré au pouvoir ça a été mieux oublier
donc nous on croit que c'est un manque
de volonté de la part d'acac d'avoir
fait ça nous on a la volonté de d'aller
chercher l'argent qui est dû parfait ce
beau chemin on va vous suivre de près
puis vous serez dans notre débat
économique qu'on va présenter jeudi à
jeudi soir avec les autres candidats
merci d'avoir été avec nous monsieur
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]